no you're horrible for asking me this
question
i did feel bad but not that bad have
chloe and the real trevor
met chloe did anything happen between
you and mitchell
after the show wrapped
hi it's lisa hi it's chloe beach and
we're here with buzzfeed to answer some
of their
burning questions
[Music]
did you have any suspicion trevor was a
catfish
of course i did like i'm not that naive
in my head i was thinking at the
beginning
he's definitely a catfish stop being a
mug
he is playing you it is a woman but then
certain things happened
like the basketball question and people
would say certain things and he would
say certain things and then we had like
a chat about
him being a single parent and him being
brought up in like a really rough area
in new york and
i felt like i really connected with him
on that level because i thought wow
we can connect on that so yeah i think
towards the end i've convinced
myself it was trevor and obviously yeah
it wasn't but we'll just forget about
that
so during the show of course i was
definitely feeling guilty and i felt bad
because i'm a woman and i know what it's
like to
like a guy and really create a bond with
them
that you don't you haven't had for a
while or
uh just something new and fresh and it
just feels good
so that's where i was feeling guilty
however i think it's game
and i knew that chloe was going to
forgive me um and you know everything
that i said it was very genuine and from
the heart
so we definitely um connected
on a friendship level i would say i mean
well she's
my girlfriend so you already know but i
i did feel bad
but not that bad you had a game to play
exactly
how often were you allowed to message
the other cast members
in the circle chat like i think you'll
agree with me delisa
you have to be quick when you're in the
circle chat
because someone there's like what eight
people to begin with
so when someone sends a message someone
else has already sent a message then if
someone sends
an answer and then a question three
other people have then jumped on it and
you're like oh my god who am i replying
to
so you need to be quick with being able
to speak to the circle for the message
to send
to actually be involved in the
conversation otherwise you're just
sitting there panicking like
i've missed out on so many questions
that was me i panicked so much
because i missed out on several things i
wanted to say because the conversation
just jumped to a whole other topic and i
was still on this topic and i was like
ah what am i doing on the show it looks
like the chats are like
five minutes but the chats are much
longer than that
i would yeah it just depends how quick
you are so you can message as much as
you want it just depends on how
fast you can go how many days total
did you live in the circle apartment and
what did you do
during your down time i can't actually
remember how many days we were in there
for but it was definitely
like a few weeks in my down time i would
just like
eat food if i had like a burst of energy
i would run round on my
teddy unicorn i would do rolly pollies
off of the bed
i would nap 24 7. oh there was times
that i definitely napped and i'm just
like
i hope they didn't get me snoring
because i was i was playing sudoku
that is my game oh my i could be anybody
in sudoku okay so don't even try it i
also
live for different looks and different
hairstyles so i was really playing with
my wigs and like
um just you know prepping them up and
getting them ready because you know i
never knew what type of look i wanted to
go for
just being a super girly girl because i
was being a guy the whole time
so stay true to myself and who i am did
trevor
think you did a good job of portraying
him in the show
how did he prepare you before heading to
the circle apartment
so trevor obviously thought i did an
amazing job because i won i mean like
what you mean oh he was exceptional he
studied with me he quizzed me um
he i had a book i had a notebook and i
had
information on everything it takes to be
a guy
um well at least that guy okay i was
definitely
prepared i felt very prepared and a lot
of the information i didn't even have to
use which is the funny part
i had how many baseball basketball um
football teams there where i had all the
names of them i had their mascots their
colors
i had uh different brands of alcohol
that he drinks that men
drink because like i don't drink whiskey
and stuff like that name brands that
guys would wear where they would shop at
oh my i had everything types of haircuts
like see i was saying like low-cut
scissors with a deep wave you know
that's the beyonce stuff but he was just
like
no that's not what you call it it's
called a fade and like i had
brands of like hair like hair cut
trimmers and stuff like that like
i had everything in there like there's
like nothing
that you can ask me at that point
because i don't forgot it all but it was
all in that book i was prepared honey
he's
also my number one supporter and he
encourages me with anything
and i think even if he felt i did a bad
job i don't know if he would tell me
you know that's my that's my husband
he's gonna build me up before he knocked
me down
i have chloe and the real trevor met no
we haven't to be honest i feel really
awkward
yeah i just feel really awkward i'd just
be like no
to be honest i don't think i've looked
at trevor's instagram page just because
i feel
bad because like me and elisa are now
like really good friends
i wouldn't want her to think that i'm
like trying to steal her husband or
anything
so i'm just like no trevor who it's de
lisa that i was talking to the whole
time yeah
i don't know if i would meet trey bark
i'm just going to stick with me and her
girl you got to meet him one day i'm a
package dude
he's a cool person so i don't think he's
necessarily like dying to meet khloe
because like
he might feel weird as well right but um
i think i'm the only person that's cool
with it like
beautiful girl beautiful guy hey say
hello okay
that's it you know but he'll be down to
meet her for sure he's shorter than you
though khloe so
i don't think that you would be
attracted to anyway i'm glad
i think he's shorter than you or maybe
he's your height i have to be six
five for me to even blink an island yeah
so you're not blinking
chloe if it came down to it would you
have aligned with the kardashians
or the trifecta um
you're horrible for asking me this
question
ah i don't know i think it both helped
make me kind of
calm second like i almost won because
i had aligned the relationships i had
without meaning to
i don't know that is my answer i don't
actually know like see what i mean i
could never pull off being a catfish
because my memory and my
attention span and my it just doesn't
work
i don't know what's going on up here
anyway but yes i i don't know
i feel like you would have picked the
kardashians
over the trifecta i don't think i would
have i don't know i think i'm swaying
more towards you and mitch
because the kardashians so much drama
went on with them
i don't know but then also there was
drama with trevor and
mitch when they came to me and they were
like
catfish to let you know that the
kardashians were drama
i thought oh no mitch's brain was trevor
now trevor's on his side what do i do
i can't say anything because it's a
popularity contest
yeah that's what i was thinking i
figured that's why you would pay i knew
that you would always have my back
oh yeah 100 you're like i think mitch
you was questioning his game yeah i mean
mitch i didn't trust 100 and i didn't
actually know if mitch was real or not
so
to be honest in answer to your question
now i thought about it i think i'd
choose the kardashians
yeah but as a group not as a person
obviously my favorite person was delisa
trevor because
we had each other's backs till the end i
mean even when we were standing on stage
holding hands
till then my baby which catfish from the
season was the most
shocking me no no actually
i want to say it was a river and lee
like i was just like
whoa i i never expected it to be
an older gentleman because it was just
some it was certain lingle that he was
using that i was just like okay so he's
definitely young
i couldn't figure out who this
person was behind the scenes and it was
extremely shocking
to find out that it was lee like when he
walked through the door
like my heart fell out my ass i think to
be honest like
jack and lisa
walked in i was like netflix now i think
you've made a mistake
they've already been kicked out and then
i sat
there and everyone got up and was like
oh my god i can't believe it and i was
just sat there like no
this is wrong they've already been
kicked out what are you doing
and then i had to sit back and think oh
oh so they're recycled catfishes they've
been kicked out then brought back in and
i get it so that was the most well
actually no
trevor was the most shocking the most
confusing catfish
was jack and lisa chloe did anything
happen between you and mitchell
after the show wrapped wouldn't you like
to know
all i'm gonna say is sparks were flying
at the finale
we shared a kiss he asked to kiss me
we've been in contact ever since and
we've been facetiming each other like
almost every day
so and i've even spoken to his mum like
my family know who he is
and there's been talks about me going to
america and like
moving over there so yeah it was so
unexpected though
obviously like my tactic at the
beginning was just to flirt and then
when me and trev hit it off
and then mitchell come in i was letting
mitchell and i felt bad on trevor and
then mitchell was like oh you're
basically like a sister to me let's just
drop it
and then when trevor turned out to be
delisa i was like okay now i can
actually talk to mitchell about feeling
guilty and now it's like wow
how have you spent some of your winnings
oh well as i mentioned
in the circle i really wanted to win for
my family because
we need a house and we've never had
that much money to put down for a down
payment um so
i'm in my house i got my house
um as soon as the show finished
we came back and we started looking
immediately and
we just hit the ground running it was a
long process we haven't been here that
long but
i definitely got my house and my family
were just like extremely blessed and
grateful and happy
to not only experience this but um
basically take that w home and
really put it to the use that i wanted
to i mean i guess since this is coming
out
afterwards i'm gonna find i'm gonna show
but you know
i am
we have another one on the way um
yeah so it really went to
like the use that i i wanted it to go to
um for my family i did it for them
amen and thank you my circle family
because
they believed in me and well i don't
know if they did or not or if it was
just like their game plan but hey
i won for sure i know i know out of
everybody chloe genuinely wanted me to
win
everybody else might have been planned
but at the end of the day i know they're
all happy for me and i thank
everybody for it and this is a circle
baby here
coming soon